well my first epiphany i think
in terms of physics
was um
probably when i was around 11 years old
and i i
luckily
um my family came in contact with the
indian guru at the time that was
teaching
um
meditation during that time there was
not a lot of evidence
back in the 80s and 80s that said it was
possible in fact you were considered a
hippie right yeah but now you fast
forward to today and because information
is so available and people are starting
to apply that information
now we're starting to see dramatic
changes we've done numerous brain scans
to show that you can change your brain
in four days meditation meditation i
don't have time to meditate people are
high sick and broke on their mom's couch
meditate so i do two 20-minute
meditations every day
there is a mantra that you're given when
you get trained in tm
you don't tell anybody your mantra
uh and you repeat your mantra and you
repeat run so you close your eyes relax
wherever you are even if you're in the
back of an uber or whatever you know if
you're busy you got to do where you got
to do it and you sit in your tm and you
repeat your mantra and then your mind's
gonna wander you're gonna hear something
you're gonna get taken out and you just
return to your mantra then you'll get
taken out again and you'll turn to your
mantra and then the more you just allow
the mantra to take over the more you can
go into that transcendental state where
it's you release your thoughts
and your body
your cortisol levels drop
and you just you're just
really really supporting your nervous
system uh that is my anchor i was
burning paulo santo today i held
crystals and meditated
you know i love meditation too oh you
know i was just listening to something
other the other day i don't know if you
ever listen to abraham hicks now she's
like all you need to do 15 20 minutes a
day that's all you need to do and all
you need to find not all 20 minutes but
just one of those minutes if you can
just get really quiet like really
silence your mind it's enough and i was
like
okay
that's all you need to hear sometimes is
that like because again we nobody's
really like saying like oh i know how to
meditate i'm really good at it you're
like am i i don't know i'm doing it
right but to hear that you just need to
take away a minute from even a 15
meditation like that just changed my
life with meditation you say you're
telling me that
80 percent
of a thousand people
had a more than 90 percent change in
their brain for the better just by
practicing meditation
we know that you can train your heart to
work more coherently that means that
when you're angry when you're frustrated
when you're impatient your heart beats
out of rhythm that's how powerful you
are
and it really suppresses
certain genes so then change your
emotional state
wow you start to see people practicing
this kind of regulations we have
evidence that people can do that we have
evidence you can change your genes in
four days you can change your gene
expression you can make your immune
system stronger by changing your
emotional state you can lengthen your
life
with um
just
60 days of meditation five days a week
we've proven that you can lengthen your
telomeres so now you have evidence that
common people can do the uncommon enough
to be a monk you don't have to be a nun
you don't have to be a priest an
academic the common people are beginning
to wrap their minds up on this and do
there's evidence this isn't just
mystical information so there it is
science is that model and then we have
testimony like we have people that have
healed themselves of stage four cancer
not once not twice not three times and
four times over and over again we have
people that have healed themselves that
were blind that were deaf that had
tumors
that had graves disease hashimoto's
syndromes numerous parkinson's patients
brain injuries uh
ms rheumatoid arthritis and rarity
that's the stuff jesus was doing back in
the day i mean that's what i'm hearing
as well then like take baby steps if you
have a hard time meditating just
take it to a minute a day just
concentrating on your breathing for one
minute then try three minutes that's
what i did my mind is always full of
chatter i can only do 10 minutes at a
time that's what works for me i think we
put pressure and we think things
connecting with our loved ones has to be
this or it should be this or it should
feel like this
it's a simple thing of sometimes i smell
cigarette smoke i know it's my my dad's
mom i know it's her
and i learned to meditate
and at the time was very you know
unusual thing to do never mind at the
age of it at 11. i i was thinking like
what is this meditation thing what am i
doing and then i thought well i'm
turning my senses inwards right and i'm
kind of listening to what's going on in
there and
so my first epiphany was oh
there's a world inside
and there's a world outside
and in between is a boundary
and this information going in the
boundary and this information going out
the boundary right when i do things i'm
putting information into the outside
right and i'm
capturing information from the outside
through my senses so i was thinking oh
so that was my first thought uh in this
evolution of physics is oh
so the the exchange of information could
be the source of the energy of creation
i become really cool means absolutely
still and cool
i'm never excited when i'm driving very
fast i'm like
very very almost become cold literally
simply alert and there no no excitement
no adrenaline no such thing in my life
actually you have not enjoyed the power
of stillness that's why you think this
is
this is better amphetamine is better
than being
still
stillness is the nature of the existence
over 99
of the existence which is not material
in nature in this entire cosmos right
not even one percent is material
existence rest is all absolutely still
this is the lap of creation
you must be there always because you are
a piece of creation you are best only
when you're in the lap of creation i
went on an airplane
and this woman next to me looked at me
and she said you're so full of light
and i at that time
literally just started this quantum
shift i still had a lot of ego and a lot
of arrogance i was working for lee
steinberg i was running the most notable
sports agency in the world my friends
were the most famous people i still was
rich
and i looked at her and i said thank you
and she said do you meditate how could i
manage i made everything myself i
literally listed out what i had oh wow
ferrari apportioned like she's like he
needs to work on his narcissism oh yeah
yeah i listed out like the ferrari the
porch the houses the ski mountain golf
course i run lee steinberg have you
heard of lee steinberg ever seen the
movie jerry maguire like this is where
my ego was still and she looked at me
and she said
oh that's too bad she goes because i
could teach you to vibrate faster
and i'm looking at her like what she
goes the earth vibrates the slowest then
plants animals humans then sound then
light then thought she goes do you know
what vibrates the fastest and i was
literally still arrogant i'm like no
she goes the truth
and literally the hairs on my arm stood
up she goes the truth vibrates the
fastest you cannot be aware of anything
that vibrates
right just lower than you i can elevate
your vibration so you can be aware of
the truth don't you want to know the
truth i could teach you whether to buy
or sell that's an awareness
stress is when your brain and body are
knocked out of balance
the stress response is what your body
innately does to return it back to order
all organisms can tolerate short-term
stress
but the chronic stress is what pushes
the genetic buttons that create disease
now
most stress ends up as emotional or
psychological stress so physical stress
trauma accidents injuries falls chemical
stress toxins pesticides pollutants
bacteria viruses molds hangovers and
then you have
emotional stress family tragedies second
mortgages single parenting 401ks you
know traffic whatever
and
all of those things knock the brain body
out of homeostasis
but the emotional stress
is the challenge because the person can
be taking care of their body you know
eating all the right foods taking all
the drugs taking all the right vitamins
all the enzymes doing the things doing
yoga during long distance running
whatever it is that they're into
but if they're living in constant fear
because of some threat in their outer
world that's either real or imagined or
they're they're so
uh mismanaging of their thoughts that
those thoughts keep producing the fears
they're turning on that stress response
by thought alone
then they could eat the most organic
healthy diet do all the right exercise
but the body's living in survival
because that's stress so now you're
mobilizing all this energy for some
threat in your outer world and there's
no energy in your inner world for growth
and repair and so you your body is
actually
utilizing all of its vital resources
when it's feeling fear when it's feeling
aggression or anger when it's feeling
pain and suffering yeah the body is
mobilizing enormous amounts of resources
if you're being chased by a tiger you're
not going to use 20 of your resources
you're going to go all in right so then
what if it's not a tiger what if it's
just traffic
so what was once highlighted
becomes very maladaptive and when you
turn on the stress response and you
can't turn it off now you're headed for
disease